we had tasha in
love and brandon
saying good bye
and ben coming
back yeah there he is hi ben oh hi ben
oh this is your the bachelorette season
finale part one recap grab your glasses
it's time for roses and roses
hi everybody it's me lauren zima
oh babes we are live and i don't know
why
i'm dressed like this i don't know why i
wore this
i've been watching too much of the crown
i think
at my couch at home and i've been
watching the crown in between
the bachelorette but we are talking
about the bachelorette finale i am
dressed like a beatles fan but i
am a bachelorette fan everybody so we're
gonna
get to it i want you guys comments and
questions from tonight's part one
episode one of the bachelorette's
two-part two-episode finale leave your
comments
leave your questions on our youtube page
on our social media i will be getting
them here on my ipad
and i will be answering them and giving
you my thoughts and to do all that i
will of course need
some um beverages
in my glass is it's just the one glass
but we're gonna be drinking so
let's do a little toast to tasha here we
go
[Music]
oh it was quite cold oh very british
bottle popping yes
it's indeed it was you can also leave
your comments and questions on my
british accent below
i'm trying to sound quite posh although
if you saw roses and jose last week you
know that
i did my impression of voldemort which
you guys seem to love
so here it is again
okay i'm done anyways everybody fill up
your glasses
we just had our handed to us on tasha's
part one finale cheers let's get to
it oh
all right as we continue with roses and
rose live i gotta do the graphics myself
everybody so first of all don't drink
every time
we had to be honest tonight
thankfully i couldn't have three better
guys to be honest with you
they're honest loyal i'll be honest
with overnights like it gets harder to
be honest with you i
honestly don't know what to think
anymore you guys
my first thought about this episode and
let me know in the comments below what
your big overall thoughts were
i don't know what to think anymore
i mean i love this show it's the gift
that keeps on giving but
i cannot figure out who tasha's into as
much as i
so very clearly knew
who claire was into like just the one
person like it was just dale like dale
dale dale dale day all day
i cannot discern who tasia is really on
board with
she said i love you to one person
tonight to zach we're gonna talk about
it all right
so let's be honest do you know what is
going to happen
it's been a very emotional season oh
don't drink every time i just rhymed
your comments and questions already
coming in uh
norma says i don't like zac he looks
like he is hiding something oh
norma okay aj wants to know why she's so
into zack well zack is the one that
tasha said
she loved oh marie wants to know why i
don't think if tasha a day between
fantasy suites to sleep
um i actually do think that the lead
always gets just a little bit of time in
between each fantasy suite it might have
seemed like she didn't but i do believe
she has a moment
um bean said bb says did you bring a
spoon of tea well this is my version of
tea
oh yes jelena says she had real tears
when brendan
left oh and robin likes the balloons
thank you i did not mean to dress
like the balloon that was an accident
but
here we are we love a good aesthetic
shriek
all right everybody so tasha was being
honest and she honestly
started her fantasy suite with ivan
so ivan and tasha had their fantasy
suite date and
it was a date it kind of felt like a
first
one on one to me they did this fun
silly world longest coldest kiss
date they had to try and set the record
for the world's longest
and coldest kiss what did you think of
them doing this date for their fantasy
suite they had quite an intimate moment
really holding on to each other
uh to try to survive to be honest with
you uh they were shivering
and freezing and i think that they were
just
holding on for dear life at this point
now does that connect someone you know
just trauma
bring us together perhaps um so i also
had questions about the semantics of
this you know what was the temperature
what is the world's longest coldest kiss
record who was it set by allegedly they
beat the record by one minute
what i did like about this was that ivan
did reach down and he he didn't have to
make more of his body cold but he did
because he wanted to hold on to tasha he
reached down into her ice bath if you
noticed
there were underwater cameras so we did
see some of it and he held on to her
okay
because ivan is very into her okay
so ivan and tasha are holding on to each
other and you know what let's just have
some fun it's the finale
don't drink for the whole time they were
freezing
it is freezing we're both freaking out
like i truly don't think i can actually
do this
at that point i actually started to kind
of like go completely numb
they were numb you know they were numb
and um
they do bond again through this date
you guys's questions and comments are
coming in more
um oh as someone said they love my
outfit thing
should i try like a cockney accent thank
you so much thank you
i don't know what this hat is but i'm
having fun with it
um faith from boston says that she is
team ivan she sees the connection
if tasha doesn't choose him in the end
she hopes that he has a chance to come
back in paradise or maybe even as
the bachelor rachel from pittsburgh says
these dates are crazy do you think they
actually broke the record and kiss for
six minutes
i do think that they did kiss for six
minutes i don't think they made that up
i just didn't know what this record was
what was the temperature
can anybody look into this and let me
know in the comments below what is this
real
record uh yasmine how did they come up
with these dates yasmine i think that
they've run out of things to come up
with on these days
we have been at the laquinta for weeks
and weeks at this point they've not been
able to travel as they usually do as you
guys know
and i do feel that we are seeing the
repercussions of that
the guest judge with chris harrison on
this date was paulie
who is a wonderful man he's the head of
i believe uh
sort of security for the show so they're
just pulling crew members in now you
know
we got no more people to quarantine and
we got no more creativity
so ivan and tasha um it was hot in la
quinta and you got to freeze um
emily is wondering does tasha have real
chemistry with any of these guys i can't
tell if she's connected to them
emily that's an interesting question and
you guys tell me what you think
as we got into the dinner date with ivan
i've wondered this the whole time about
tasha and
ivan do they have chemistry i think that
they're really
connected to each other they have a lot
to talk about a lot in common but i
don't know if
the chemistry is there so speaking of
the emotional moment comes
we're trying to figure out where is
tasha at who is she really connected to
and ivan at this point had not told
tasha as far as i know correct me if i'm
wrong that he was falling in love with
her well
they told each other their feelings
let's take a listen
i am undoubtedly falling in love with
you right now
i definitely have been falling for you
[Music]
too
so what do you guys think
[Music]
oh um matt says ivan is great but
watching his slow march to getting sent
home is brutal okay
oh crystal says i look like hermione
granger thank you crystal
the deepest compliment of my life i
usually look like
voldemort
i gotta stop not everybody watches harry
potter lauren um
okay so ivan and tatia they just have
told each other they're falling for each
other
but i'm just purely talking about
my sense of the chemistry here i didn't
feel
the fire now tasha goes on to say we
didn't see it in that clip but she goes
on to say that ivan is
the perfect guy that he is i believe and
i quote
literally everything so my question
in hearing her say those things because
i always try to look at what they're
actually saying is
why isn't he just the one then and there
why isn't she telling him she's in love
with him
and the only conclusion that i can draw
is that the physical
chemistry the connection
isn't there that there's no spark and i
don't believe the spark always has to be
there from day one you know we saw with
claire and dale
that was all about the spark being there
from day one minute one
but i think the spark can come i just
don't
know that it has to come with ivan and
tasha what do you guys think let me know
in the comments below because otherwise
i don't know why
they're not just
in love is what i'm saying now what they
are
in is in an airstream um this was their
fantasy suite you guys and
it's not for me you know i gotta be
honest we got some champagne and that's
great verve
seems to be sponsoring the season i
don't know what donut company is but
you know that that's an airstream that's
a nice trailer and um
i um i would have said no i would have
said wow i was
uh literally numb earlier and now i'm
sleeping outside
in a metal box and it's not feeling
feeling very
fantastical to me what did you guys
think would you like an airstream date
i felt that i haven't got the short end
of this stick if i'm being honest
i know they're trying to switch it up be
a little creative but i wasn't very
impressed
rachel says can we talk about how ivan
got a tin can while zach got a mini
castle for the fantasy suite rachel
we're discussing it and thank you for
saying that
oh another commenter saying notice that
tasha said i'm falling in love with you
to ivan but directly said i love you to
zach
let's get to it so zack gets
the second fantasy suite and zac and
tasha
oh they're not ice diving they're paint
rolling they are painting with their
bodies
they are rolling around in the paint
it's getting sexy yes yes yes
you want to talk about chemistry here it
is
they've done dates like this before but
never one on top of the shag rug that
felt risky
so sorry to that rug um that
is the chemistry you guys that's what
we're talking about you know
tasha wanted to grab that hiney it seems
i don't think it was for
an artistic endeavor i don't think we'll
be seeing this painting and this work
in a gallery uh i want to note that zach
and tasha got to do a hot
shower together after their date rinse
that paint off and i would like to know
if i have an anticia got the same i
don't think that they did
so zach and tasha they do the painting
date and in their nighttime portion they
also
confess their feelings to each other
let's take a listen
i know that i love you i love your smile
your strength how you treat other people
i just love
the human being that you are like i just
see it but i think it's important for
you
to know that so
i don't know it's just wild
because i love you too and it's only
i've like known that i love you though
that's the thing it's like i don't think
i've ever felt this way before
i don't i don't think i have
the love cup runeth over i mean the
difference you guys the difference
if we are talking about zach and tasha's
conversation versus tasha and
ivan's i mean she is all wrapped up
in zach and look at this fantasy suite
that they got i mean they are bopping
around
indoors with candles lit everywhere with
air conditioning
and central heat they have got
a beautiful bed that is not tucked
inside of a metal box and
they've got i believe uh some rose wine
and that's a treat
yeah okay so definitely an upgrade now i
like ivan a lot
i think zack's great too these guys are
all great tasha has a
wonderful final group of guys don't you
think is there anyone who stands out
above the others for any reason any red
flags going off for you let me know in
the comments below
um but zack and tasha you know zach said
earlier in the episode that he has had
nothing that's been a warning sign to
him he said that this was all about
tasha and he wanted to see what happened
for her
and tasha had talked about how from the
beginning she thought zach was indicated
different
and zach liked that she said that and
she said she was trying to find
something wrong but she couldn't i mean
this is what
she wound up saying take a listen
zach loves me and i love zach
[Music]
you guys that smile that glow zach loves
me and i love zach it was we were
getting back to claire loves dale
territory in that like giddy schoolgirl
happy way and i'm not
faulting that you know what i mean i
just felt like tasha and zach
it might not might not make as much
sense on paper as ivan
and tasha do but there seems to be more
of that chemistry and connection there
now some of you have talked about uh
yeah we're saying there's definitely
chemistry with zach
kathy says tasha is into zach because he
makes her laugh he's silly like jpj oh
interesting insight yes
um it is
you know i'm i'm thinking about what
somebody said earlier that they weren't
sure about zach that something felt off
and zac and tasha did get into this
discussion about how
zack had said that he had
not that long ago thought he wasn't
ready for marriage and kids and he says
tasha
has made him realize he is now i will be
honest with you guys
that's a little bit scary to me because
it's a real quick
turn around on a very major thing
marriage and kids it's no
small topic it's not like you know what
i was a cold brew guy but now i like
espresso i don't know
it's children okay and
on the one hand i think it's romantic
and beautiful that zach says tasha made
him realize that he does want to be a
father
on the other hand it worries me a little
bit i'll be honest because i want zach
to come to that realization on his own
i think that's a safer way to do it than
to be fueled by
uh these feelings these emotions for
someone else you know it's gonna come
from you it's gonna come from you what
do you think
am i wrong am i being too cynical is
this british outfit making me like a bit
too cynical
let me know in the comments below
hurry stop it okay who else is
definitely something suspicious with
zach is he pulling a jed no i don't
think that he's pulling a jet he seems
very in toutation
i'm almost worried he's so into tasha
that he's like backtracking on
ways that he's felt for years although
by the way if zach wasn't sure if you
want to get married
kids why did he come on this show
questions i have
questions i have ashley says never
thought i would miss the clarity of
clarendale
i wrote that down in my notes ashley i
am wondering if that's ashley crosston
i wrote down in my notes that we use
that
i i'd never been more clear with
clarendale and now i've gone to the
other extreme and i've never been more
confused than with tasha
um so that's
zach and tasha now they are electric
they've got the chemistry
and when zack goes back to the other
guys
don't drink for all the awkward silence
how are you doing pretty good everybody
good you look good
ready to go
so
do you think they know do you think
they're like zach and tasha
a lot of the times guys will come off
the show and they will say that they
could always sense that
the lead had this chemistry with this
other i'm very interested to know if the
guys all
said that i will say hold on let me find
it let me find it
nope nope where is it oh shameless plug
i did speak to noah and blake
and they both said that they thought
that tasha and zack would be together at
the end of this those guys both thought
that that was how it would end that was
their prediction um but
noah said that he had some concerns with
zach and his readiness for marriage as
well so you can find those interviews
vtonline.com
how much you you know rely on or believe
in
blake and noah's take i don't know let
me know in the comments below uh
caroline said what did you think of
chris harrison's outfits i love them
i love them all what do you think of my
outfit
i don't love them all there have been
times but i love them all tonight okay
so next up we have brandon in the
fantasy suite
but it was far from a fantasy for
brendan
wasn't it everyone oh brendan
bren done wasn't it bren
done oh so you guys brendan of course
has been
divorced don't drink every time i just
rhymed are you guys at home safely i
hope you are
brendan and tasha have discussed this
and you know this just felt like a real
uh i guess i've got to use a sports term
here is layup correct
for the producers they chose to have
brendan do a date with tasha
where they pick out
wedding rings
he probably would have preferred the ice
bath
brendan and tasha are sitting down with
neil lane himself
and they are looking at wedding bands
and you guys
you guys you guys don't drink for every
time brendan
looked uncomfortable so don't get
nervous
those are french cut diamonds in the
middle
it's called an eternity this love of
your life forever
i'm brendan
it looks like brendan was using every
muscle in his body to not run right
and i don't mean that because he doesn't
think taisha is great
i mean that brendan looked like his fate
was flashing before his eyes
and that it was uh all coming into
perspective for him in those diamonds
and the reflections of those lights and
the cut clarity and color of the
diamonds wasn't it so
brandon looks tense you know and tasha
uh says that she can sense that
something's off
really
yeah you know what let's have a little
fun they sit down to dinner and
don't drink for every light
thank you
yeah i haven't got those uh snowflakes
brandon had a little light shed on his
situation okay
more comments and questions coming from
you luanne says they sabotage brendan i
don't know luanne that's interesting
i don't think it's sabotage i think what
the show
often does is puts a spotlight on what's
going on inside you
you know uh i mean one date
with tasha one experience shouldn't have
been strong enough to like totally sway
brendan from a way he didn't already
feel you know
i think it just shined a light again
through those beautiful
perfectly selected diamonds of neil
lanes onto brendan's true feelings and
magnified them
do diamonds magnify things i don't know
let me know in the comments below i'm
british
okay so uh someone says brendan looks
like a ghost
oh so brendan and tasha sit down to
dinner
and tasha asks him what's going on and
you guys
you guys you guys
brendan's answer to tasha was one of the
most real
and captivating and heartbreaking
moments i've seen in some time on the
show let's take
but knowing you're ready uh because you
want something so bad
and and uh you know i want the wife and
and um
i'm sorry okay um
brandon nearly cried and i nearly cried
what did you think of that
moment brandon was being so honest
he said that he just didn't think he was
emotionally healed he didn't think he
was in the right place to give teisha in
his whole heart and he had realized that
and so they break up and deja is
walking brendan out
and my heart is brand and breaking
oh and then and then
and then tasha says
this i really thought i was going to be
with him
i really thought i was going to end up
with brendan
[Music]
he's been a person every single day that
i've been like it's brendan
every single day every single day
i've been like it's brendan every single
day
she just said she was in love with zach
she said ivan was literally perfect he
was everything
so who is tasha into
let me know in the comments below i
don't know
were you guys surprised brendan
self-exited
please tell me let me know in the
comments below i was
actually pretty shocked so brennan
leaves and tasha's hugging him goodbye
and they are crying and i thought to
myself oh
gosh it's just like that blake goodbye
are we once again leaving our angel
human mermaid goddess tasha
in the streets crying as the car pulls
away
and the answer was yes it was yes
so tasia she winds up alone in the
fantasy suites you guys
she does still have some champagne with
her but the bucket is
unopened it's unopened
two glasses one lasso
last british word for woman anyway
she can still drink it's okay babe i
don't know why she walked over two
glasses that was pretty funny
um and then we
get a major moment
ben is back oh and he's not wearing
socks that's interesting he wore capris
that's a choice oh is he wearing a scoop
deck shirt it's a v-neck that's the ben
we know and love
ben walks in and he has returned after
being eliminated last week after not
being able to tell tasha he was in love
with her and here's what he had to say
about the situation
how do you feel about her i'm in love
with her
i'm a very lucky i'm in love with hey
and i need to tell her oh
so ben knox the door opens
and ben goes to speak with tasha
and he tells her that he's in love with
her do we have the clip
hello program
can i come on yeah please
i know i'm catching me off guard and i'm
sorry
i just really need to talk to you
you guys tasia's face in that moment
i oh i didn't know how to feel about it
listen i
completely understood where ben was
coming from when he said
that he felt like the way that he
antacia's
breakup happened wasn't reflective of
their relationship i thought that was a
beautiful way to put it
and he wasn't necessarily saying you
wanted to come back into her life but he
needed to tell her how he felt he needed
to have that closure
and he got it and he told her he was in
love with her take a listen
but i'm in love with you
i have been in love with i have been in
love with you i uh
now i'm starting to get nervous um
i i blew it by not telling you in the
[Music]
moment
oh where was your heart at at this point
in your stomach in your butt let me know
in the comments below mine was on the
floor
um so tasha doesn't know what to say
you know she walks out of the room and
she sees
she says what we've seen her saying in
the promo clip
which is and i quote take a listen
there's a pro ceremony what do i do with
that
what does she do with that
what does she do with zach what did she
do with brendan with ivan oh brenda's
gone what does she do with ben
oh my gosh were you guys shocked that
ben returned i have to be honest i
wasn't
um because they did end in such a weird
way gina says ben
showed up that's what tasia wanted i
think she'll bring him to the final rose
and the proposed as much as i'm sick of
the phrase show up this season
from what we've seen in the trailer for
tomorrow night's episode you guys it
seems like ben sticks around he seems to
be there we see him
in several scenes and we see tasha
in tears in this white dress i did speak
to chris harrison in an interview and he
told me that tasha's tears oh wow by the
way i have a way to wear a turtleneck in
brendan's absence
so there's ben and chris harrison said
tasha's tears might be from her love and
i quote
not being reciprocated what is going to
happen we also know
that tasha's dad will be there he was
incredibly influential on colton's
season he had a lot to say
he told her not to microwave love well
what will he have to say tomorrow night
uh christy kay says her reaction is
basically
what the i
oh i felt that ben handled the situation
really really well
the question is just is it enough at
this point everyone
we know that tasha has told zach she
loves him but we also know
that she said she thought brandon was
the one every single day and he's gone
we know that she wanted ben to say i
love you and now he's done that and we
know that she says
ivan is literally everything
that's where we're at everybody that was
the bachelorette night one
part one i have loved getting you guys's
comments
and questions and we will be back
tomorrow night so everybody we raise the
glass to tasha
we will see what will happen i cannot
believe how incredibly emotional
this season of the bachelorette has been
and i have never felt this
unsure of who the lead could wind up
with in
the end so you guys we will be here
tomorrow night again
right after the finale episode arizona
abc will be live at 7 p.m pacific
10 p.m eastern and i will have more
champagne
so everyone i love you so much haley
says does brendan come back i don't know
anything could happen at this point
couldn't it
i love you i raised my glasses to you
you can find me on twitter instagram
cameo and of course here on roses and
rose everybody
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you